hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast live stream number 143 what 43
143 it is that's right
um so product of two of two primes the
product of two primes there you go there
you go
uh probably yeah oh yeah all right I'll
go with that probably
yeah that it probably has a name yes I'm
I'm confident that it probably has a
name
all right so I think we need a
disclaimer or two here let's go with
three
all right you're gonna have to do the
third disclaimer I've got a couple of
disclaimers so
um we are still engaged in moving and
that's going to be a process that
continues for some time pardon our dust
actually some of our dust is just
literal dust at this point we've got uh
a lot of that circulating we also have
um both picked up a cold through Toby
who brought it home from the school
thank you Toby for that
um it's just a cold but it's just a cold
but here's the thing some of you
um tune into Dark Horse for the biology
and you're in for a treat because it's
going to be more biology involved in
today's Dark Horse than than is
ordinarily please no I shouldn't have
said that all right well those of you
for whom that was uh a targeted comment
um or triggering you know who the most
biological triggering it'll be
triggering for most but for some for
some that comment was for you and you
know who you are
as such uh we are just going to do the
main uh show today we're going to not do
the Q a uh because we might not still be
um upright in so far as we are currently
upright by the by the end of a q a
apologies for that but hopefully we'll
be back next week with uh both the live
stream A's to your cues
yes right
um also I believe
um impacted by our Uh current level of
drippiness and coldness
is I will be doing two of the ads today
two of the ads which while that is not
exactly
um like reading War and Peace it's kind
of for me like reading War
um but yeah you know we'll see how it
goes okay I've got the third disclaimer
awesome yeah no I knew you'd be thrilled
the third disclaimer is
big apologies for those of you who can
hear the birds in the background yes
what are you gonna do oh we've got the
door open and there's birds yes these
these uh birds are spectacular though
not real
um in any case I mean just in keeping
with the whole Birds thing
right like all birds exactly I'm told
these are I don't think there are any
birds yeah they probably can't hear them
really okay well then the disclaimer was
unnecessary but it's you know you have
safety first thank you you are welcome
for protecting you from the sounds of
birds how's that yeah
all right all right uh so let's see uh
we are gonna uh
appreciate and read about our sponsors
but first let's just see uh yeah we're
not gonna do the Q a today
um oh one one announcement that I wanted
to make is that because we have moved as
we have announced
um
up here to the gorgeous farthest
northwest corner of the lower 48 United
States in the San Juan Islands uh which
is part of an archipelago which includes
the Canadian Gulf Island son of which is
relevant to what the announcement is but
that may be sort of what happens today
um it's sort of a run-up to the
announcement yes uh so we sometimes
receive wonderful mail letters and
packages and such and on our websites
and our book website there's been an
address in Portland uh PO box that you
can send links and packages to and while
our mail has begun to be forwarded it's
not clear to me the packages have been
forwarded and so we may have lost some
things in this uh in this transition but
we have a new a new PO box which I'm not
going to announce here in part because I
didn't write it down but it's on our
websites now um so
uh so if if you for instance did get
something returned to you and actually
still want to to send it on to us uh we
uh we really appreciate almost
everything that we get from fans yep uh
increasingly we uh could use the lumber
diesel fuel all sorts of things that are
in short supply you should check whether
or not these things are very workers
Ferry workers yes don't send those to
the mail though I'm sure there's laws
against it Ferry workers fairy
godmothers really you know
spelled differently she says as if that
matters as if spelling isn't an
afterthought to language which it quite
clearly is by many thousands of years
probably hundreds of thousands before
thought to fairies I know before that
isn't a thing no yeah I like it though
before I thought yeah yeah before I
thought all right
um yeah we've got we got a store
darkerstore.org home we're on YouTube
and odyssey both film uh don't worry
about that's yeah I don't know why that
my link here says that'll work okay
darkhorsestore.org
um
well we've got Natural Selections where
I actually posted and excerpt a couple
of excerpts this week from 100
gatherer's Guide to the 21st century in
honor of the year anniversary of that
book coming out which is now also
published in several other languages and
we appreciate you we're supported by you
our audience we appreciate you
subscribing to the channels liking
sharing both our full episodes uh and
our Clips at Dark Horse podcast Clips
which is a channel on both
Odyssey on YouTube and having having
been demonetized by YouTube to spawn the
basis that our content was not uh
conducive to them finding ad sponsors
for us and then of course adding ads
just not paying us for the fact that
they've done so we are doing other
things like being uh like telling
telling you uh that we have been
demonetized and that we appreciate any
support that you can offer us you can
join either of our patreons tomorrow
we have our monthly private q a at 11
A.M Pacific for two hours that you get
access to through my patreon for
Saturday and Sunday usually every month
Brett has
um Brett has more intimate conversations
associated with his and on both of them
you can access the Discord server which
right now several members of the Discord
server are actually in a real-time
camping trip and enjoying themselves
rather a lot
um I hear so that is the sort of thing
that can happen as a result of access to
the Discord community
and of course we do have sponsors and so
as we've said before we only accept
sponsors who make products or offer
services that we actually truly stand
behind
um for any number of a number of reasons
and without further Ado we're going to
start
[Music]
you are going first but somehow that's
they have gotten in the reverse order
yes but seamlessly without the people at
home being at all aware that it has
happened we've switched the order back
to the correct one our first sponsor is
bubs Naturals Bub's natural sells three
products that are becoming ever more
popular in Fitness and outdoor
exploration circles collagen protein MCT
oil and apple cider apple cider vinegar
gummies
uh there are a lot of companies already
selling these products but bubs is
different and here's how
the products themselves are of the
highest quality carefully and
sustainably sourced and bubs is a
company with a conscience bubs is named
for former Navy SEAL Glenn bub Doherty
who was great friends with the people
with people from all walks of life
including one of the founders of Bub's
Naturals
for 364 days a year 10 of all profits go
to a charity in Glenn's honor and on
Veterans Day that number is 100 bubs
Naturals encapsulates Glenn's enthusiasm
for life self-improvement and helping
others with the motto feel great do good
try Bub's natural collagen protein which
is truly unflavored I can vouch for that
and soluble unlike some of the other
collagen protein on the market
it's got just one ingredient which is
critical for joint and gut health and
Muscle Recovery and you can add it to
anything a glass of water a smoothie a
cup of coffee and Bub's Naturals
collagen bubs Naturals collagen protein
is sustainably sourced from grass-fed
and pasture-raised cows in southern
Brazil
very far from the Amazon and the MCT oil
powder dissolves fast in coffee for
instance providing a healthy sustained
mental boost both the collagen protein
and the MCT oil are easy to add to any
drink and help with both mental focus
and muscle and joint wellness and
Recovery furthermore the apple cider
vinegar gummies have been a huge hit
with many of our friends and family
everyone who tries them seems to want
more Bub's Naturals aspires to these
words die young as late as possible what
a great slogan that is
go to bubsnaturals.com
Darkhorse for twenty percent off your
order
we haven't unpacked the tell story yet
but you doing okay
um well that there was there was some
roughness in there the the reading
through me a little bit but I think I
think we got through it you're halfway
there I'm halfway there all right
we don't know that yet but it's looking
the chances of my failing to do it are
now down by 50 percent
um our program is also brought to to you
today by Seoul a sustainable Orthopedic
footwear company Seoul is one of our two
Footwear sponsors and we love them both
they are quite different from one
another yet both have an evolutionary
approach to creating shoes that help
feet get and stay healthy and become
more mobile Soul intentionally brings
structure back with both their shoes and
their footbeds soul Ames with its
Footwear to return our feet to health
and the shoes by Soul are beautiful
sole footbeds are the industry standard
for over-the-counter supportive insoles
and inserts they are moldable for custom
comfort giving you all the benefits of
personalized support at a fraction of
the price of orthotics sole footbeds
which are made from recycled cork
include a signature supportive Arc which
is clinically proven to reduce Arc
strain in your feet by 34 percent this
is especially effective in helping
recovery from plantar fasciitis
a disease that I know how to pronounce
because I've had it which affects more
than 2 million Americans along with a
range of other ailments from shin
splints to hip knee and back pain sole
footbeds also promote neutral alignment
and good posture and are particularly
effective at preventing fatigue when
standing for long hours on hard surfaces
Seoul has a campaign right now to end
foot pain in North America which they
are facilitating by sending a free
footbed to every zip code on the
continent Darkhorse listeners should
visit
yoursoul.com Darkhorse
and if you live in a zip code or postal
code in Canada where Seoul hasn't
shipped you you receive a free
performance medium footbed that's your
soul
y-o-u-r-s-o-l-e.com slash Darkhorse they
believe in the quality of their products
so much that they're sure that once you
feel the Comfort pain relief performance
enhancement and injury prevention
benefits of sole footbeds you will want
them in every shoe you own simply enter
your ZIP code or postal code in the
shipping section at checkout and you
stand a chance to get a fully totally
free footbed while supplies last there
are more than 41 000 ZIP codes in the US
so you've got a good chance you could
have a free footbed coming your way
two points of order yes
plantar fasciitis isn't really a disease
it is a in addition it causes dis-ease
okay so I believe it is a disease
um yeah in any case I've had it and it
sucks
I think anyone who's had plantar
fasciitis uh can I can attest that it
sucks
um and then I will just say that I've
been wearing the sole uh they claim to
be flip-flops but they've got the
structure they've got the sole structure
the sole footbed and the uh the uh a lot
during the summer and now into the early
fall and they are fantastic really love
these yeah me too yeah okay final
sponsor of this week is mud water
mud water is a that's
m-u-d-w-t-r mud water is a coffee
alternative made with four adaptogenic
mushrooms plus herbs and spices with 1 7
the caffeine is a cup of coffee you get
energy without the anxiety Jitters your
crash of coffee more to the point I
think it's delicious
each ingredient was added with intention
it has cacao and chai lion's mane
mushrooms cordyceps chaga and reishi
turmeric and cinnamon this is a terrific
product either on its own or as a warm
drink in the morning you can drink it
black or with cream or honey or both mud
water also makes a non-dairy creamer out
of coconut milk and MCT and a sweetener
out of coconut palm sugar and lucuma
which is the fruit of an Andean tree
used by the Inca
to add if you prefer those options this
week I was drinking it hot with a bit of
their creamer plus a small spoonful of
honey it was as I said before delicious
no
there's
I told you there was going to be more
biology in today's Dark Horse yes so
he's barking at Toby who has shown up
there's definitely hit chocolate in the
flavor and the Masala chai blending it
yeah mud water makes you bark
there's definitely a hit of chocolate in
the flavor and the Masala chai blend
including Ginger and cardamom nutmeg and
cloves and lately I've been blending it
into a smoothie also with the banana and
Ice some delicious and local made
entirely nut milk mint and cacao nibs
it's totally delicious and they've got a
wonderful new caffeine free product
designed to be a drink from before bed
which is also wonderful mud water is 100
USDA organic non-GMO gluten-free vegan
and kosher certified mud water allows
you to build a morning ritual that
promotes sustained energy without the
crash so visit mudwater.com Darkhorse to
support the show and use Darkhorse at
checkout for 15 off that's
mudwtr.com Darkhorse use dark horse at
checkout for 15 off
foreign
there is all the domesticated biology
showing up and making noise today yep
um that was our epic Tammy Fairfax who's
just coming to yell at us
um that's it for the ads that's it for
the ads
all right
um well let's um let's launch into it
let's launch into it yeah so I wanted to
do a kind of view from 30 000 feet of
where we are and I think the the title
of this section is
some stories diagnose a system which is
something long time viewers of Dark
Horse will have heard me say before but
I want to give a kind of refresher what
that means before we get to the specific
example diagnose the failure systems are
just no they diagnose the system what is
the state of the system right so
the first example of this is the
Evergreen story
um Evergreen what happened to us at
Evergreen diagnosed
certainly diagnosed the College of which
we were apart for 15 years but it also
diagnosed the university system right
something happened to us at Evergreen
which revealed a pattern that was common
across the academy but it wouldn't be
obvious how common it was for a couple
of years right
and so the story was really what happens
when professors who have an excellent
track record on issues of race sex and
gender
stand in the way of diversity equity and
inclusion initiatives because those
initiatives would be bad for the college
that they're part of right and in fact
bad for the people that they were
ostensibly designed to to help right we
saw in the Evergreen story exactly what
happens which is that a phony story of
racism
is generated and it is used to support
riots to force the hand of the
administration and the administration of
course uses this uh as a a bit of
Leverage to remake the college for their
own purposes right bloating
Administration Etc
so the Evergreen story diagnosed the
system by showing you by it's like
luminal in some sense luminol during the
uh the substance that is uh sprayed on a
crime scene that then allows UV light to
reveal uh where there might be blood or
bodily fluids right so some stories
function like that election fraud some
stories function like luminol they
function like luminal election fraud is
another such story right we can see by
the way the uh the Press has dealt with
the question of election fraud in the
U.S that uh effectively what we have is
no longer a press interested in finding
the truth what we have is a press that
is interested in the team sport of
politics that basically highlights the
possibility of election fraud when it
works against the team that they're
affiliated with and uh obscures it when
it works for the team
um that they are affiliated with right
so we can see we're Once Upon a Time the
idea that there could have been a
distortion in the American election
would have been a tremendously important
story that would have been of interest
to anybody who was patriotic and
interested in the health of the nation
now we know that the Press has taken
sides and they will only look at the
story or frankly invent the story
um uh in service to one team and not the
other and so both of your first two
examples
uh Evergreen as diagnostic of the larger
system of higher ed and
um coverage of a less of election fraud
as diagnostic of Journalism at large
speaks to two systems
that are explicitly supposed to be that
in fact do not function if they fail to
be nonpartisan nonpartisan is the
shallow end of the pool they excuse me
they uh journalism and higher ed broadly
explicitly needs to investigate means to
encourage the investigation of stories
such that the truth is discovered
and it feels like you're gonna go a
third place uh which I'm I'm betting is
going to be science which is the biggest
one of these if if science uh doesn't uh
if if what we are calling science
has a pre-drawn conclusion and there's
only one thing that you're allowed to
conclude regardless of whether or not
research was done or not regardless of
what the data say or don't uh then
you're not doing science any more than
you're doing journalism if you only
cover one side any more than you're
actually engaged in an act of of higher
education if you allow ideologically
motivated people to draw attention away
from you doing something which is
actually antithetical to higher ed which
you know it is in part as you said about
bloating Administration
well you're close you're what you're
suggesting is certainly included in what
I'm uh going after here the third
example my third example diagnosis a
much larger system and in fact I don't
think it's a system that has a name you
know we can talk about our global system
and that has a kind of a vague limit on
it but I would say we are all embedded
in uh a
nested hierarchy of systems right and
what covid did was diagnose the entire
thing and I'm afraid that what it has to
say is
uh terrifying frankly
um okay so then let's
um let me say that not knowing exactly
where you're going with that that
um you can you can put the third thing
in there that's at the same kind of
level that that is science oh it's that
higher ed you've got journalism and
you've got science and you know
I I would not want to be the person to
rank the importance of science versus
versus journalism in a functioning
Society higher ed also being necessary
but uh you're you're then going to talk
about some umbrella thing that doesn't
even have a name it's so big and
amorphous but certainly there are
aspects of what happened in the last two
and a half years that reveal the what we
call science and many of the people we
call scientists are actually no such
thing oh yes I'm absolutely going to
suggest that one of the
subsystems that is diagnosed by covid is
science and it is beyond unhealthy at
this moment it's just embedded in a
larger Network and you know
I don't know whether science is more
important or less important than
journalism in a functioning system I
would say having a functional scientific
system and journalistic apparatus are
both prerequisites so the point is there
isn't a more important you need both
those things you know in order for your
car to function is the engine more
important than the transmission
um you know no you need them both to
work
um so in any case what I'm going to
argue is that among the things that
kovid has revealed
is that journalism is completely dead
right the fact is there are stories
inside of the covid story
that are just waiting for a journalist
to take them seriously to investigate
them without partisan commitments and
follow them where they lead huge stories
stories that in the world that you and I
were born into were not only the kind of
thing that would make a journalist's
career but they were the kind of thing
that altered history where journalists
revealed something and the powerful were
in no position to stop it and these were
the things around which history pivoted
and the fact that we've got these
stories and can see them we can name
them and yet there does not appear to be
a journalist who regards themself as
capable of pursuing it or that they are
ready to confront the kind of power that
they would have to confront in order to
pursue it is is very shocking so we'll
return to that but journalism is one of
the things that is clearly diagnosed by
the coveted story The failure of certain
stories to be systematically explored by
um you know not not even just a
journalist but some newspaper or
journalistic magazine that wished to
ascend to the top of that hierarchy
right could do so simply by pursuing
these stories if something else weren't
uh
taking priority taking precedence yes
yes
um the second thing is exactly what you
mentioned it's science
we are I think
living in a dark age I think that has
been
arriving for some time I strongly
encourage members of our audience who
have not listened to my conversation
with Steve Patterson to to do so he and
I discussed the question extensively he
has a different approach to the question
of whether we are in a dark age but
nonetheless I think
the idea that we might be and that the
evidence is actually persuasive is
something that is
um it's profoundly important because of
you know
is it more important than journalism who
knows but is it vitally important that
you have a functional truth-seeking
apparatus able to figure out what the
basic facts imply right of course it is
especially you know the more
technological and complex Our Lives
become the more important it is that
we're able to sort signal from noise and
figure out what we're doing that uh is
inflicting harm on us and what we might
do that would make us healthier and
safer
another system that is clearly diagnosed
by this is universities and it turns out
that whatever universities were
previously they have become effectively
churches that exist in service of a
particular team's articles of faith that
is to say they rationalize belief in
certain things that may or may not be
supported by any evidence right A Team
declares that something is true and then
the university provides what appears to
be science that suggests that it's true
irrespective of whether or not there is
an equally compelling or more compelling
body of evidence that suggests that it's
false right that is not the function of
a university as it has been defined
but it is the way that these things are
behaving
yeah and you can't claim that University
acting that way isn't a university I
mean you might but because University is
defined as a much larger and more
amorphous thing
um that's that's not the kind of claim
that I think you or I would make um but
you can we
can and will and have said actually when
you do it like that when you have a
foregone conclusion and you look for
evidence to fit that or to uh to analyze
in such a way data to analyze in such a
way that it can be made to look like it
fits
that's not science it's not science
right it's not science and the you know
it'd be one thing if it was just simply
not science but when it's dressed as
science and it's specific so it's
basically sucking up all the oxygen in
the room for doing science right and not
doing it that's lethal I've heard my
science for the week done the science oh
man yeah I so follow the science yeah I
followed so much science I was exhausted
it was like yeah I'm going after pizza
man I'm saying stuff
um
but
um
yeah it's well it actually suggests
something I've said in a very different
context
you know I've argued that the the
American Founders made an error for
which we can't hold them responsible
because of when in history they existed
they built an evolutionary system they
built a system that had all of the
necessary components for it to evolve
without building in a structure that
recognized that and uh counteracted it
right so the point is they built
something with the intention to create X
but because it evolved basically it
found a niche and became why which is
something being pretty darwinian they
could not have properly anticipated and
they did a hell of a job though oh they
did they did they far exceeded
expectations
um given what they knew but given what
we now know the answer is look anytime
you build something with all of the
characteristics necessary to make it
evolve a you'd be a fool to think it
won't and B you have to do something to
deal with what it's going to evolve into
and the right thing to do
is to make sure that it can't find a
niche that does things that you don't
want done right so our system has
evolved into something without a name
and it masquerades as a Democratic
Republic and it serves some other
function and the universities are like
this too right the universities because
of the reward structure in them have
evolved to become this church-like
entity with sacred beliefs that cannot
be challenged with evidence right that
thing was inevitable that this would
happen but it results in this other
thing that we've talked about
extensively which is
the mismatch between the contents of the
box and the label on the box that's
right oh it says University on it oh
this must be a place of Truth seeking no
yeah it was at one time but it has
inverted its purpose right it's now a
truth obscuring entity yeah well I mean
this a lab coat is a kind of label I
said last week I think lab coats are
cheap labels are cheap it's a lot
cheaper to change what you call a thing
or what you slap on the outside of a
thing than it is to change the actual
thing itself right and it is also you
know a lab coat is a cloak and the point
is a cloak is an obscuring
um
entity it it obscures something and so
the point is if you were to invent a
universe something that does what modern
universities do
nobody we would spot it we would
recognize it as a hazard it is only
because it is dressed in sheep's
clothing that we don't notice what role
it is taking on well
a bit here I don't I don't see a lab
coat primarily as a cloak or a you know
a wolf dress in sheep's clothing I think
unfortunately what it is it's you know
it is the Insignia of I am you know I am
a Scientist and of course there's lots
of us who do science uh who don't do lab
science and so have um relatively rare
reason to be wearing a lab coat but I
think for me you know I used to in the
beginning of my evergreen programs in my
like what is science lecture so yeah
what do you need to do science glassware
you need a lab coat you need a PhD and
of course you need none of those things
and this was the point but the lab coat
is this
um in premature it's this it's the
symbol
um that suggests that what's inside is
going to be a real scientist but
actually anyone can put on a lab coat
yeah well all right but then this
metaphorically this is particularly good
because if you think about what the lab
code is right where it came from
science is messy
you don't want to get it on you right
that's what a lab code is for right you
are going to be doing science and
whether that is Caustic chemicals or am
I talking metaphorically here no I'm
talking quite literally that science is
messy you don't want to get it on you
because it could be pathogenic it could
be poisonous it could be caustic it
could be a lot of things and so gross it
could just be gross but the idea that
this thing is supposed to protect
um what is inside and it is now become
its inverse it now hides what is inside
what is inside is now the dangerous
thing right and it is uh making it is it
is very much like like the metaphor of
sheep's clothing
um from the point of view of an
unsuspecting public that doesn't really
get that what makes something science is
this particular adherence to a method
and the philosophy that underlies it and
it is not the Walks Like a scientist
talks like a scientist thing which is
now very misleading yeah
yeah I guess I mean
at this point it's going to feel very
semantic too
a lot of our items for a long time I
think for me the the main problem with
the lab code is not that it can obscure
um but that it appears the same that you
know that the the institutions of higher
ed themselves have become so corrupted
that uh the granting of the PHD that
enables you to have the lab that enables
you to have the lab code or you know
maybe it's just you know you're a you're
a lab tech in a lab and you're mostly
washing glassware but you still have the
lab coat many people will view the lab
coat as uh oh okay well then I'm gonna
I'm gonna ask that guy
because you're wearing the thing that
tells me that you have some kind of
authority and so it's it's the
it's the use of the lab coat as an
indicator of authority that I find to be
the giant risk and you know I mean and
he's too easy a Target at this point and
it's just remarkable to me how
politicized this has become the idea
that those who criticize faucier
inherently on the right is insane it
really makes the left look like a bunch
of baboons frankly and you know we're
not not all of us but you know fauci
claimed to be science on more than one
occasion and uh he ain't and he wasn't
doing it either he was a political
animal the entire time and maybe he was
a local baboon I don't know yeah well
I'm not disagreeing with you um I would
point out that the Milgram experiment
more or less exactly tested this
question that somebody was dressed as
scientists carried a kind of authority
that would cause people to harm other
people yeah
um but I would also point out what were
really you know go one layer down from
what we're discussing
and there is a an underlying truth which
is to the extent that something carries
special Authority it is going to be
targeted and captured and it's going to
be worn as a cloak right so what is the
New York Times it is the paper of record
except what it is now is some propaganda
rag that is owned by we don't exactly
know what and you know speaks their
sacred truths as if they were actually
true and so you know that should not be
surprising the fact that there was a
paper of record makes it an irresistible
Target for capture and unless it had an
incredibly good immunity of course it
was going to be captured and you know
likewise universities of course they're
going to be captured likewise Wikipedia
oh my God there's a free encyclopedia
that serves nobody's interest because
it's non-profit wow what a tantalizing
thing to capture and get it to speak
your particular propaganda because
people take it as impartial yeah right
so basically the point is as soon as you
establish the thing that we all need
which is the voice that does not pay any
heed to people's Financial interests or
power
so once you've got that thing you've
also put a bullseye on it right it's
going to be targeted for capture and if
it if you don't protect it then the
point is it's going to become your enemy
well and capture can look a lot of
different ways
what I'm about to mention but I think
for instance with newspapers with
once journalistic or aspiring to be
journalistic outfits it can start this
way and I mentioned this uh when I was
in college I did a bunch of research
into
uh Publications that are aimed at women
so this but this would have been in the
early 90s this is this is in a different
era back when everyone understood what a
woman was for instance
um
and
Gloria Steinem who at that point I had
nothing but respect for
uh who founded uh Miz well no she didn't
found but I think I want to say I think
this is true that she oversaw the
founding of ad free mins I don't know
that she was one of the founders of the
original Miz I'm not I'm not totally
sure now I haven't looked this I didn't
re-look into this today but she wrote uh
she wrote some stuff
um after the initiation of ad free ms
which started up in the early 90s after
Ms had been around for a while about the
ways that advertisers the you know the
reason they had gone ad free
and
as she described it and no one has
argued that she's wrong here in fact
there's lots of corroborating evidence
basically the advertisers in mins as a
you know a publication aimed at women uh
demanded
certain kinds of editorial content to go
on flip sides of pages with ads and and
things like that and in fact began to
make even you know bigger demands about
uh you know having difficult stories in
an issue at all with any in any kinds of
ads and this is obviously exactly
antithetical to journalism and it's part
of why we avoided doing ads ourselves
for a while you know we thought you know
we have we need to retain a firewall we
need to be very very clear about never
taking any sponsors
um simply because oh wow yeah we could
use the money that's good money like
nope we're only going to do it for for
products that we actually can vouch for
but
when you are an organization that is
growing
that has lots of people involved that uh
that you know the revenue stream is
depending on a lot of things and uh and
add you know would-be ad sponsors start
coming in and saying well
we could promise you six months or a
year of you know regular ads but we're
definitely not going to want our ads in
the same section as a new discussion of
I don't know what it's going to be War
abortion
uh you know pedophilia
uh there you know there are a lot of
true and ugly things in the world that
need to be discussed need to be capable
of being discussed in any outlet that
claims to be doing journalism where if
they're being told uh at the outset in
order to have a business relationship
with us so that we can help you pay your
bills and keep your lights on you're
going to have to make sure that you
don't say anything about that topic
which you might otherwise have said
something about that's the beginning of
the year yeah I mean and let's uh I
think we can't be complete about the
taxonomy but an Advertiser might not
want you especially conscious
right because most products function the
desire for them is not rational and it's
subliminal and so anything that causes
you to be in your critical uh in your
critical mindset
might be counterproductive they might
not want things that are a buzz kill
um because you know you might be feeling
positive towards a product and then
discussion of War as you say or
something might cause you to be feeling
not so good and that could be
counterproductive or inconvenient truths
right uh Inconvenient Truth
right and so you know I
we can get off this topic immediately
but
we have turned down many sponsors more
than we've taken and the reason is to
make very sure that nothing compromises
us
um you know we are in a position where
we have to take sponsors in order to
survive because you know uh YouTube for
example has taken up arms against us and
really obviously would prefer we not be
on the air
but nonetheless taking things that we
have thought through carefully whether
or not they do compromise us and that
our advertisers have thought through
carefully that they are willing to deal
with our complete Independence to say
whatever needs to be said irrespective
of what mindset it puts people in or
very often encouraging of that right and
that's you know that and that's part of
what makes an excellent relationship
right right um actually we know what you
are yeah we know that you know what
you're explicitly independent uh
thinkors who will say what you say and
that's part of why we want to support
you that's that's amazing and that's
what any relationship with an outfit
that calls itself journalism we don't
actually we've never used that word
about it so that's what I'm talking
about you know New York Times anything
like New York Times to tough Poe
um both of which I think aspire to
journalism I think uh but are clearly
engaged at least to some degree both of
them and uh to in every larger degree I
have a toughbone forever but
um to an Ever larger degree in
producing stories that tell one side of
every story and that's it and if you can
rely on that then you have to know that
you're not getting
the truth the whole truth and I think
about the truth right or you know wapo
is true democracy dies in darkness the
New York Times is all the News That's
fit to print you know these are just the
tag lines of these papers that I can
come up with off the top of my head they
all sound something like that and then
you know similarly the universities
which is where you started here right
the many of the universities have uh you
know some version of truth truth above
all truth and light uh you know in often
in Latin as their as their mottos and
boy does it not seem like that's what
most Universities at least in the west
are standing for anymore Veritas TM yeah
yes right all right well so now in
special reality filter like yeah
truths you'll love
um okay so we have so far said that
kovid has diagnosed the journalist
system that it apparently there is no
journalistic system because we have
giant stories that in the in a past era
would have been an obsession of
journalists that are almost untouched
we have said that the scientific system
is broken we're apparently living in a
dark age and even the basic fundamentals
of how science is done are not being
followed
the universities which were once these
truth-seeking establishments that were
independent and they were supposed to
follow the truth wherever it led have
become uh Protectors of particular
articles of faith of one team and not
the other
and then the next level which we haven't
talked about yet is that the U.S
government is apparently
completely captured and
it is captured at Best by private
interests that are at best indifferent
to the suffering and death of average
citizens right and I say it best because
there are far worse possibilities about
what they're up to but the indifference
or who they are that they display to the
harm done to the public and the
murkiness of who's interested is that
they are serving is mind-boggling right
and covid made it so clear we watched
the entire system fail and not once not
20 times we saw a hundred different
failures that all looked alike right
they started them in real time and yet
seeming to be in slow motion
all you had to do was be mentally
independent in order to watch the system
predictably follow a particular
narrative irrespective of what evidence
loomed up in front of it right that was
an amazing fact right and and it took
over everything so all right you had a
government which I'm certain was never
free of corruption
but
at one time it functioned to a large
extent in the interests of the American
people and we watched covid reveal that
it's not in that business anymore no
percentage of it no percentage of it is
interested in the well-being of the
American people right that is a uh and
and uh
inconvenient obstacle that has to be
addressed only in as much as elections
require it to be addressed right and to
the extent that it can be done entirely
at a narrative level so no actual uh
bending of policy to the citizenry has
to occur all the better from the point
of view of whatever it is that's
captured our governmental structure and
whatever purpose it's on about I really
don't think we know but we can see it
isn't about us right that's just simply
where we are and then the last one of
these that I think covet has diagnosed
and you know maybe our our listeners and
our Watchers will find others that I
haven't spotted
is that covid revealed that National
sovereignty
barely exists anymore
right the degree of coordination of the
corruption over National borders yes
there were differences but the basic
point is something is in power across
the west and it
it got almost every nation to march in
lockstep
uh
in
complete indifference to the
countervailing evidence that says that
at least if if it were true
that the system were in fact confused
right if this had been some massive
error where people who thought they
understood things better than they did
had screwed up right there would have
been a wide diversity of approaches
across the west and we didn't see that
right we saw the occasional departure to
an extent right but we did not see
a wide diversity of approaches we saw
people doubling down on the same things
that turned out to be that started out
clearly wrong and became wronger over
time and yet the the policy remained
consistent as if that evidence had never
arrived
sorry yeah well I should keep talking
except that that was more or less the
end of the uh the idea but anyway so
okay you've got
get my back you're back okay apologies
guys
um I did want to point out the
exceptions that I that I know sure which
you know you you made a point of saying
uh that they were minor and I think in
the west that is true I think you know
Sweden actually in in early mid-2020 was
shocking to most of the rest of the West
because you know Sweden being in
Scandinavia is just the darling of of uh
liberals at least in terms of policy and
somehow somehow what that has come to
mean is surely they will lead the charge
in lockstep or something right like uh
and yet from the beginning they did not
you know they they they took precautions
um but they did not close down schools
the same degree or impose masking or and
I and I don't think um ever ever went to
mandates vaccine mandates so Sweden was
a bit of an exception
in the west and in the west largely
there there were not many
but the rest of the world
the version that we hear
is
oh what needs to happen is this is about
inequity in vaccine access right and
what we need to do is make sure that all
of the poor people who I can't believe
we did this but they didn't get
vaccinated when the rest of the when the
West got vaccinated so what we really
need to do is basically cover cover
Africa with cover vaccines
so Africa most African most sub-Saharan
African countries with I imagine the
exception of South Africa and maybe a
couple of others
um is far less code vaccinated than
other other than countries in the west
and uh they were doing better right yep
and similarly Latin America uh several
countries in Latin America struck out to
some degree on their own and for
instance started started actually
engaging in allowing people to partake
of early treatment of non
um you know off
off-label drugs which we've talked about
here before and did not suggest that for
the first time in all of human history
there was one and only one way to treat
this disease oh and by the way the fact
that it is neither effective nor
particularly safe should not stop you
so it does feel like this is a disease
of the West unfortunately and there were
some there were some deviations but they
weren't gigantic whereas the deviations
to the degree that they exist were
largely chalked up in the west to more
Dei crap right this is this is more
about diversity Equity inclusion and
aren't we all really racism that's why
we haven't given them all their shots
which is you know it's just layer upon
layer of garbage thinking right it's
that's the thing is the garbage thinking
now that we can stand back and say two
and a half years down what have we
learned about our system not what have
we learned about covet what have we
learned about our system because of
coven yeah one of the things that we
have learned and this is really the
point of this particular exploration
is we have learned
it is impossible for something like
covid to happen and for you not to learn
painfully what you didn't understand as
a result of what is revealed right you
discover your arrogance right you
thought this thing was going to work
very well you deploy this thing and you
discover ah it didn't do what I thought
and what's more I did this other thing I
didn't anticipate
it is impossible for that not to happen
in a system that is actually interested
in doing better right and the fact that
our system is not obsessed with
discovering what has now been revealed
by you know our attempts to solve this
problem is the real thing that we need
to be alarmed by right that's that's
what I'm getting at is
now
in September of 2022
it is becoming apparent that the thing
doesn't care that it was wrong
um and what's the evidence for that well
for example
you have a
extremely unambiguous excess death
uh rate that appears to track our remedy
and our prophylaxis rather than the
disease itself there's some excess death
that is the result of coven but there is
a signal what do you mean by the remedy
and the prophylaxis well
The Way We have dealt with people who
are sick with covid and the way we have
attempted to prevent people from coming
down with covid right that's some sort
of medical policy
the
excess death signal
appears to track that and in particular
it appears to track the
so-called vaccines really transfection
agents but the so-called vaccines
rather than the disease itself there's
certainly an excess death signal from
covid but the distinction between the
pre uh inoculation phase of the pandemic
and the
mid inoculation phase is substantial now
a normal system
let's say that all of the people who
orchestrated policy had just been
arrogant boobs
right and they did the thing that we've
seen a thousand times where they thought
they understood the biology better and
they deployed a policy that seemed right
to them and you can imagine them talking
themselves into that belief into
certainty into certainty and then
deploying the thing and having nature uh
reveal their folly
well the natural thing that would follow
that I'm not saying this is good but the
natural thing that would follow that is
there would be a rush to shunt blame to
others there would be
a
and this is key there would be a rapid
campaign to reduce the future harm right
and that is not necessarily about
anything Noble it is just simply about
trying not to be responsible for more
suffering and death but you would not
for instance continue to see Mass PR
campaigns to vaccinate and boost your
children
right this this is the most obvious of
these things is if you were confused
about this then your confusion would
persist longest when it comes to the
people most jeopardized
by coven and your confusion would be
alleviated most rapidly with people who
were least jeopardized by covid and as
it turns out most jeopardized by the
supposed treatment exactly so we would
expect the system to be embarrassed into
functioning and it is not being
embarrassed into functioning it is
doubling down on the same insanity and
it is basically going to take that
excess excess death signal and instead
of causing it to be finite in time it is
going to make it into a The New Normal
of the rate of death now
the problem
the many problems that are Downstream of
this recognition is
if it is indifferent to human suffering
and death now
after these patterns have been revealed
was it at first
right is this a new indifference it
thought it was right and then it decided
it didn't care that's unlikely I mean
even Occam's razors wise that's two
steps
the rational thing the most rational
thing the most parsimonious thing is to
imagine actually never you never gave a
[ __ ] in the first place maybe it wasn't
trying to be right right and that's
disturbing I don't like saying that out
loud I would love to believe that we
live in a system in which people who are
truly indifferent to the suffering and
death of others are relatively rare
right that most people care somewhat
some people care a lot but I would
imagine in general that indifference is
rare that it shouldn't be common even in
the halls of power
right it should be a rare thing and the
fact that it seems to be dominant in the
uh particular places in the system that
governed policy over the last two and a
half years
ought to alarm us and it ought to force
us to engage
certain kinds of questions but then this
goes back to where I started
which is
engage these questions with what exactly
we don't have the tools of science with
the tools journalism and other things
you would learn in college right you
would expect the university system to go
into high gear figuring out how these
errors were made what should have been
done what we ought to do now right you
would expect journalism
to be obsessed with uh diagramming the
failure figuring out who actually was
responsible right none of this is
happening and
really I don't you know Dark Age I think
is a good metaphor because
the hazard of living in a dark age isn't
about being in the scientific dark it's
about all the things Downstream of not
being able to figure out which way is up
right we are stuck in a predicament
where we have a lot of things well maybe
government should fix this cool except
that the thing that is dressed as
government isn't functioning like a
government right maybe University should
figure out what's happened Yes except
that that thing is now a church that is
hell-bent on not figuring out what
happened maybe some journalists ought to
look into it yeah except who do they
work for they can't work for any major
Publications so they've got to be an
independent journalist and if they do go
after it maybe that's the end of their
career right so well many of the
institutions I mean I think you use the
word church to describe um
the university system
but I think mostly systems have become
de facto replacements for for religion
they have many you know science is
acting like you know people who don't
understand science which includes a lot
of people with fancy letters after their
names and who call themselves scientists
don't know what it is and are treating
it like a religion
many people are treating I don't know
journalism is a little a little
different but uh you know if
if if you can only speak the conclusions
that have been handed down to you by who
knows what that sounds kind of religious
um the universities are acting you know
like you know the you know the woke
stuff is acting like a religion as we've
talked about before as John mccorder has
has written about extensively uh the
government is effectively acting like uh
like a new kind of church so you know we
do have
and you know maybe by no coincidence at
all exactly as the waning of explicit
and formal religion happens people
groping about blindly not having
actually understood what science offers
what actual science offers what an
actual secular understanding of the
world can grant you and have have have
glommed onto and created these heinous
new religious-like structures that are
at least as dangerous if not more so
than many of the actual religions that
came before yeah in fact I I will uh I
will retool that a little bit
um
religions True Religions are things that
have stood the test of time and have
been shaped by selection to at least
benefit the people who uh adhere to them
to the lineages that have passed them
along
I've argued that the problem with such
things what I've just given is a defense
of such things
the problem is they may be very good at
addressing hazards that look like the
hazards of the past but there's no
reason at all to think that the wisdom
that is contained in them is any good
for a completely novel set of Hazards
right example that we give in the book
and Hunter gathers Guide to the 21st
century is were the Commandments being
written today you might imagine that God
would include Thou shalt not enrich
uranium right Thou shalt not enrich
uranium in fact God doesn't mention
uranium because God didn't know about
uranium at the time despite ostensibly
having created it
um
so you know religions are compendiums of
wisdom they are not inherently moral
that wisdom can involve you know
enslaving others but the point is at
least it was at least whatever is in
there was in some sense metaphorically
true for a past set of realities
but there's no reason to expect in a
world of Novel hazards that that you can
go to those ancient traditions and find
wisdom you probably won't and you'll
probably hurt yourself if you think you
can but the problem is the
religion-shaped whole right to the
extent that the world has gone secular
it has a niche for things that function
like religions and these modern things
that fun you know it's in some sense
wrong of me to call the University some
new kind of church
or make at least it needs the following
caveat you know a church for an ancient
religion is one thing it dispenses a
kind of wisdom of the past
we are talking about cults we are
talking about religions that have not
yet passed any test of time and in this
case we are talking about cults that
just so happen to have a business model
that uh calls into question anything
that they dispense that might be like
wisdom right it's probably not good for
you because it's paying somebody else
handsomely right so anyway we've got
that situation and really I don't know
what could be
more frightening than a world that is
being made rapidly more dangerous by the
way power that is to say political and
economic power is interfacing with
modern technology right you're in no
position to defend yourself against the
uh the novel compounds that are in your
food or your air or the inoculation that
you're being told you should get for
your health that you know
you know is it a vaccine made in a
factory no it turns you into a vaccine
Factory is that safe yeah really how do
you know that that's safe it's never
been done before right
so you're in no position to defend
yourself from these things and all of
the things that should be at least
figuring out painfully oh we thought
that was safe it turned out not to be
here's what you need to know all of the
things that should be filling in the
here's what you need to know have been
captured and are broken yes how often do
you hear
any figures in the media or science
coming and saying we were wrong
we got that one wrong the advice you
gave we gave you was wrong
we are sorry
here's what we suggest you do from here
on out here's how we got it wrong here's
what we should have understood here's
what we now get and here's how it
changes what we told you six months ago
right you should be hearing that yeah
and the fact that you're not hearing it
ought to be setting off every alarm Bell
that you have right and really I don't
know what the solution is here I do
there are some independent journalists
who I'm hoping are going to spot the
size of this problem right yeah sauger
and Jetty did a a piece I think last
week that was quite good he
continued to follow the story of the lab
leak hypothesis in spite of the all-out
effort to reverse history and reverse
the recognition that so many of us have
come to uh that this in fact is almost
certainly from the Wuhan lab yep right
obviously uh the scientific
establishment decided that that would be
an awfully Inconvenient Truth and uh it
attempted to reverse it by claiming that
it had new evidence that the virus had
emerged from the uh
from the web Market that evidence wasn't
in fact evidence and didn't in fact mean
anything in any way soccer and jetty on
Breaking Point
um went after it it needs continued to
be quite dogged on this on the other
hand I think he hasn't noticed that the
lab leak story
and the uh
repurposed drug story and the
so-called vaccine story are actually the
same story right that they are the
basically one team
had uh you know decided to portray the
virus falsely it had decided to obscure
the hazard and it decided to obscure the
useful treatments that turned out to be
at our disposal and it decided to
promote one treatment that made no sense
and it decided to promote it in a way
that was bizarrely indifferent to
whether or not you were particularly at
risk from the disease or particularly at
risk from the treatment it was offering
so in any case maybe well
maybe soccer maybe Glenn Greenwald maybe
Matt taibi maybe one of these
journalists who has shown so much
courage is going to come to see the
pattern and they are going to figure out
how to pursue the larger story and
you know the larger story
involves first of all a return to some
basic principles that every journalist
once knew right
skepticism is essential the idea that
there are certain truths that are so
important that we all accept them right
away that this is no place for
skepticism
right I can see Arguments for that in
some quadrants never in journalism right
journalists need to remember that the
conflicts of interest of their sources
is Paramount a person may or may not be
responsive to those conflicts of
interest but those conflicts of interest
exist and they ought to create a
skepticism of sources whose conflicts
are either not obvious or whose
conflicts suggest that that person might
not be truthful
it seems to me that there's a a kill
switch for skepticism that is being used
uh that a lot more people
were willing
to discuss lab leak than are willing to
discuss actual treatment for covid that
isn't one of these so-called vaccines or
the safety and efficacy of the actual of
the so-called vaccines those second two
things are touched by almost no one who
is still invited to fancy cocktail
parties right
and the the kill switch on skepticism
seems to me to be
oh but you're gonna kill people
don't go there you're gonna kill people
and as we have argued but as very very
few people other people have argued
actually the where did the virus come
from is it a naturally occurring
zoonotic virus that leapt from one
species to another
or is it a Franken virus that was put
together in a lab
does have medical and health
consequences absolutely because this is
where evolutionary biology is Paramount
as so many places but that will change
how it is likely to behave how it is
likely to evolve and therefore what we
can expect of it but face I've never
heard anyone else argue that actually
viral Origins SARS kovi 2 viral Origins
has importance with regard to health to
human health and so if the if you
believe that if and given that no one
seems to be stopping no one seems to be
arguing that from the other side then
you can go there even when it was
considered crazy to talk about lab Lake
without being told you're killing people
now
whereas early treatment repurposed drugs
vaccine safety efficacy etc those came
already packaged with the touch this and
we'll call you a murderer label yeah um
and it has this very nasty implication
right a lot of so
let's take the repurposed drugs thing
yep
the question is do they work or don't
they work and there seemed to be the
question wouldn't it there are lives at
stake either way yeah the people who say
don't talk about repurposed drugs you'll
kill people are not protecting people
what they are doing is they are
immunizing themselves from the
accusation that something that they said
will result in death now if you
argued against talking about repurposed
drugs and people die because they didn't
get repurposed drugs that work
obviously that kills people but the
point is their fingerprints aren't on it
so there's a way in which people are
motivated to stay away from certain
stories because they don't want
responsibility for the fact that lives
are at stake they hang in the balance
one way or the other right they're not
really protecting people they're not
even behaving in a way that logically
might protect people they are blocking
the question so that their fingerprints
are not on the deaths of people who die
right
um
and you know I actually I have it right
here just as you said the question of
what is covid is so fundamental right
you want to talk about a question in
which lives hang in the balance I mean
you've got more than six million people
dead of covet that's a huge number of
lives the question of what number that's
another with number
uh I don't know let's put it this way
it's their number right so
the fact that you have there's certainly
a lot of with that got lumped into yeah
but I don't even I don't even think it's
a good question because
there is never
a look it's one thing if you had covet
and you get hit by a bus and you get
counted as a coveted death as we know
happened right anybody who tested
positive was counted this way right
that's obviously a case in which you're
in the wrong category but in general the
complexity of biology means that you may
really be very close to the Grave
because hold on hold on because you're
89 years old and your death certificate
will say flute and the point is did you
die of the flu or did you die with the
flu and the answer is it's complicated
right so I mean just like actually we
shouldn't have I mean talking about this
new this perspective study out of
Thailand on um
cardiovascular effects of the second
Pfizer shot on 13 to 18 year olds okay
there's not the idea that we should have
a single treatment that is the only
treatment that is recommended for a 15
year old male an 85 year old woman is
insane yeah so when you've got a a
person who's 90 whose death certificate
says covid then we can talk about
exactly okay okay I don't know you know
maybe this was this was the final straw
on covid was a factor and that's the
thing to pushed them over and some you
know some people definitely died of
covet but a lot of people who were not
ready to die who were not anywhere close
had something happen to them and then it
turns out that they you know they got
into the hospital and they were tested
with these crap tests and you know who
even knows if you know some some of
those deaths of coven may not even have
been with Kobe because they may not even
have been positive like you know the the
everything about the test and Diagnostic
and Diagnostic and treating structure of
this of this entire disease and virus is
Beyond bad and as I mean this is this is
your sort of Central Point you keep
returning to here which is that it is so
bad and there have been so few
Corrections that we can no longer
plausibly say oh boy they really got it
wrong didn't they I'm sure they must
feel bad
right we can't say that and I don't know
I don't know how to alert people to that
problem exactly I mean we're taking a
crack at it here but but my point is
look six million deaths of covid with
covid undoubtedly a mixture the fact
that we know that people who had
comorbidities
were vastly more likely to end up in
that category suggest that this is a
complex system phenomenon that it did
damage to the body it did damage to the
bodies of people like us who are healthy
who got it right but the point is the
more things you have pushing you towards
the grave the more likely this one is to
push you over the fact of their number
says something like six million people
have already died with covet as a factor
suggests that this is not a tiny
phenomenon and it suggests that
something like six million people
um already and it's not like we've got
any control over this thing at all right
six million people already are
Downstream of the question of is it a
food practice that resulted in this
pandemic or is it a laboratory practice
right nothing could be more
consequential than this not only are all
of the deaths and all of the illness and
all of the disruption of the global
system that flowed from covid Downstream
of that question but the entire question
of the so-called vaccines and their
implication for human health is also
Downstream of that question so there's
never been a more important question to
get the answer to than what is covid
where did it come from and from the
point of view of going forward with
respect to covet as I have said from the
beginning
if it came from a lab knowing what it
was that the people who were working in
that lab were attempting to do were they
trying to make a vaccine right were they
simply testing were they trying to make
a very in fact a human infectious virus
in order to study it and then
whichever of those it was we are
entitled to know what protocols they
used and that is like a Rosetta Stone
for what this virus is likely to do
because they were selection they were
acting as selection that was exactly
what they were doing and this point has
been made before but it's just so
obvious especially when you say was it
food practice was it a cultural food
practice or a lab practice that produced
this thing which produced this crazy set
of freaking policies and you know two
and a half years later here we are very
much the worst for wear as a planet as a
as a species was it a cultural food
practice or was it a lab practice well
it's the people saying it was a lab
practice who were accused of being the
racists I can't even say with a straight
face like literally the zoonotic the
zoonotic origin people are claiming that
it's the way those crazy Chinese people
eat and do their marketing that is what
like their food market stuff that is
what caused this and those of us are
over here who's saying no actually we
think it was the bad science that was a
collaboration between Chinese and
American researchers we're the ones
being accused of being racist again like
this is just Dei god well this is you
know part of what we're experiencing
part of what you're talking about here
with all these systems interplaying with
one another
maybe could not even have happened
absent the woke absent the Dei absent
the diversity Equity inclusion stuff
like covering the entire outside because
it is the go-to argument whenever anyone
disagrees with your standard accepted
thing which in this case is well it has
to have been the food cult the you know
the cultural things of the Chinese and
how they eat it's like oh I don't think
so ah you're a racist then wait what
that was backwards you people are going
are making the opposite arguments and
somehow no one in the media is calling
them out well I mean I think it goes to
your earlier point about the
skepticism kill switch yeah right I
don't think anybody actually believes
that argument that um talking about
labels it's racist I think the question
in I mean and look we saw a certain
amount of this in the fauci emails with
Christian Anderson Kristen Anderson at
the time you know before he became such
a strident proponent of the natural
Origins hypothesis privately he's saying
to fauci actually this virus is
inconsistent with predictions from
evolutionary theory right right so then
the question is oh geez that's bad
because geez who is liable to be
responsible for this if this isn't a
natural virus uh Anthony fauci and Peter
dazic and right so the point is well
that will be bad yeah how are we going
to do away with that argument well we're
going to have to stop people in their
tracks let's begin Chinese well let's
one thing let's claim look
I want to nail it exactly your point is
there is a skepticism kill switch yep
right ordinarily when things go weird
people become skeptical right because
it's the right thing to do if you need
to nip that in the bud how do you do it
well there are certain arguments that
people have been traumatized over that
they won't touch one of them is racism
yep right so if the idea is hey if
you're going to say laboratory we're
going to say racist the point is oh damn
didn't see that coming don't want to be
accused of racism I know it's really
really bad for your prospect going
forward racist murderer
well anti-vaxxer well okay but no racist
murderer it's the it's exactly the same
thing oh you can't go there you can't
say you don't approve of the thing
because this disease kills doesn't it
well yes and we've got the Cure I don't
think it is secure ah right so it's not
then you're a murderer so you've got
racism you've got
um
superstitious
unscientific
backwards religious person right that
argument was used all over the place
here right it is those who are following
the science that are saying XYZ and if
you are somewhere else then you are one
of those those you know deplorables
deplorable Hill folk whatever it is
that's being leveled you know likewise
conspiracy theory no yeah right sure
right oh you're you're trafficking in
conspiracy theories am I uh and if we
decide that we can't talk about
conspiracies then you know were anyone
ever to conspire I mean I know it's
never happened yet on planet Earth but
were someone to invent the idea of
conspiring and we've been forbidden in
advance to talk about it aren't you
effectively handing them the game I
watched our cats conspire this morning
cats are solitary like you know this
this is an insane argument yeah it's
it's nutty and it never held any water
but I think you you know your point
about the skepticism kill switch is it's
not about it holding water it's about
it's spooking you away from following
evidence yep right that's right and and
that's where We've Ended up which then
brings us back to the journalists right
there are no journalistic institutions
that function but there are some
journalists who still function right
Sagar
mataibi Glenn Greenwald SCI Hirsch right
um these are all people who could
potentially see the big picture and
start following it
and because they're supported by
comparatively independent I don't know
inside Hershey's case but in the other
cases I mentioned they're supported by
their audiences they could potentially
um stare down what will come back at
them right but they're going to have to
remember their skepticism they're going
to have to remember the conflicts of
interest that sources have and uh
they're going to have to you know ignore
bad evidence no matter or bad
information no matter how
authoritatively it's dressed
um because journalism functions as you
know one of very few checks on political
and economic power and it is obvious
that whatever it is that has taken over
our system is sort of loosely in the
neighborhood of political and economic
power right we don't know what it is but
we can see what it does
um
and you know
certainly
I would say certainly the place to start
and the place
as you point out the
source of the virus is somehow more
explorable than the other questions
surrounding coven right
we did surprisingly well on that topic
because people I think probably
misunderstand how much still rests on on
the question
um
but at the point that
some journalist or some set of
journalists starts pursuing this
they're going to have to recognize that
you know if we can go back to the entire
diagnosis of the system right
we are living in something that is
functioning like uh
a Dark Age
we have to figure out because much rests
on I mean look let's let's talk about
the question of the the origin of the
virus more directly
if the virus came from nature without
human meddling right if it came through
the wet Market because somebody brought
a wild animal there that had the virus
and it jumped to people and created the
pandemic then that suggests as we've
discussed before on Dark Horse
that those who were rapidly working
their way towards understanding these
potentially pandemic viruses weren't
fast enough right we didn't fund them
enough we didn't do enough gain of
function research right whereas if this
escaped from the lab then the exact
opposite is true right if this is the
result of our gain of function research
program to study these viruses that were
argued to be potentially pandemic
starting an argument that I think was
way overdrawn because jumping from
nature across species barriers is far
harder than they represented it
um but if it turns out to have come from
the lab then the point is this is
entirely a self-inflicted wound the
whole pandemic right and so everything
hangs on that question and it has to be
nailed down it cannot be
I mean I feel like we're looking at the
tobacco Industries Playbook right of
trying to muddle the evidence right
trying to make it impossible to figure
out what's true so most people will
simply move on and the point is how much
damage has this done I mean even if
covet were to disappear tomorrow
the disruption of our global system
right the inability of Supply chains to
function the fact that we have you know
labor shortages that make certain
essential processes uh completely
unreliable right that is all Downstream
of this one question so it has to be
studied and likewise
the the issue of
let's take for example
the health consequence of the one remedy
that was pushed on everyone yeah
this is not a difficult question
right it is a noisy question right
there's plenty of statistical noise in
the impact of a particular remedy that
was administered to billions of people
but it is a question that science is
well positioned to answer relatively
easily we can't say what the consequence
of those inoculations will be for people
decades in but we should have a rapidly
accumulating body of evidence that says
what is the effect when you're at what
is the effect three years out right that
body of evidence should be accumulating
and we should be getting smarter as a
result of it right this is something our
University this is this is the shallow
end of the pool from the point of view
of logic and study this isn't
technically difficult this isn't
statistically difficult this is
something what you need is to compare
groups and these you need to have large
enough samples that you address the the
question of noise and you figure out
what the signal is it should be easily
done and again we're looking at
something
that is apparently not interested in the
answer to that question
which I think then
it it leaves us at the following
um
uncomfortable end point
which is
if our system
is not interested in figuring out now
what the consequences of Its Behavior
were
that means that it is indifferent
to the suffering and death of
millions of people
if it is indifferent to the suffering
and death of millions of people now
it is at least strongly possible that it
was indifferent from the beginning that
it wasn't ever especially interested in
protecting people it was interested in
doing something else that has never been
shared with us
and so I think we have to ask
in light of the obvious evidence of
cover-up that we've seen the cover-up of
the connection to the Wuhan lab the
cover-up in fauci's emails the cover-up
of the harm to healthy young people who
never should have been advised to get
these inoculations in the first place we
have to ask the question
what did The Architects of this policy
know
and when did they know it right it's a
traditional journalistic question you
have to follow the money and we have to
know what did they know and when did
they know it and I will point out that
there are certain things
which would be decisive if we understood
them
for example
did these people
when they got covered
have access to repurposed drugs that
they claim didn't work or didn't they
what did they have access but did they
use did they use did they Avail
themselves of drugs that they advised
others not to use
did they get the vaccinations did they
get the same ones that other people got
did they get particular ones right or
didn't they right what did they know and
when did they know it and I'm not
claiming that we can access that
information that we can discover and I'm
not claiming to know but I think the
point is
we've seen enough evidence that the
trials revealed hazards of these
inoculations
that
it's not obvious that the people who
push them hardest
got the same shots as other people got
and
um a journalist should pursue that that
information because if they didn't then
that would tell us that actually this
was not a massive error that has been
followed up by the indifference of these
people that it was in fact in fact
indifference to the suffering and death
of uh strangers that existed from the
beginning
indeed
all right
um
let's do one more very very short thing
sure that actually does tie together
although it ties not exactly where you
just ended but where I thought you were
going to end a little while ago
um
there's another skepticism kill switch
there's there's many of them I think
um but a newer one than murderer or
racist
is Turf right trans exclusionary radical
feminist
uh which you know some people have uh
started to take on as a as a label that
they are proud of because it is so
clearly uh an absurd epithet but
um I wanted to say with the with the
Preamble that I have made a point of
basically not looking into what we think
we know
but I want to say a tiny bit about the
the shop teacher with the giant
prosthetic breasts in outside of Toronto
who went to school into High School uh
wearing these crazy things and Zach do
you have a screenshot to show
um
so can they see it now
yeah okay so
um this is
batshit crazy right this is this is this
is a dude uh mask below his nose I mean
that's that's the silly part of it
um and you know I don't even know what
these are porn breasts something sex toy
breasts uh with giant nipples showing uh
that he he
declared himself a woman recently and uh
and is apparently teaching shop
uh
using this saw on the right here for
those just listening and
you know as far as I know the mainstream
media which has the well-known liberal
bias has not touched this at all except
maybe to denounce the right-wing media
including Fox of course and you know
things like the daily wire and other
places for being basically turfy and
transphobicy for saying that this is a
this is a problem
and there there are a lot of true things
that you can say about why this is
um inappropriate
right uh this is that that is not a
woman
that is uh appears to be
a man living out a sexual Kink uh in
front of children and uh forcing uh
public school you know young adults but
you know high schoolers uh to engage in
sexual to respond to sexual display
because he's he's their teacher but the
thing that actually maybe most interests
me about this because you know that's
that's just more of the same you know so
much so much of the trans activism
is not about the tiny tiny tiny fraction
of people who are really truly trans but
about women and Womanhood being
appropriated and disappeared and uh and
um pretending that what you know what a
woman is is a costume that you can wear
uh as opposed to actually being a hell
of a lot deeper than that
but the piece of this story that I think
that is interesting to me is this is
this is a shop teacher and again I have
not I have not gone into the biography I
don't know I barely know more than what
I've said here and I did that sort of
intentionally because I'm sure there's a
ton out there
um but a shop teacher
shop like a lab
the very first moments of the very first
day in shop or lab have got to be the
safety lecture with things like
closed-toed shoes only and if you've got
long hair you pull it back
and uh you know maybe you even have to
you know secure it under something
and not only is this guy wearing these
crazy ridiculous boobs
um but he's also got this wig I assume
uh long flowing blonde dresses that are
also not tied back as he's operating
this chop saw maybe miter saw miter saw
um
and
you know that's that's not what shop
teachers do
and this makes me think this makes me
hope
that this is this is a big troll
uh that this is someone who is so done
with the nonsense with the Dei nonsense
with having your words policed and
starting to have your thoughts policed
and being told that all you have to do
is uh decide that you are the sex that
you're not born to and suddenly you can
get away with everything well this
person is going to put a just a
grotesquery a clownish caricature of
Womanhood on
make it hypersexualized with the you
know with the erect nipples and come to
class and do this in front of of
students
if it was an English teacher
unfortunately it'd be like okay
I'm I know their English teachers this
confused but if this is a shop teacher
who actually still has all of his digits
or even is just missing a little bit of
one or something but learn the lesson of
whatever happened
um there's no way that this that this is
for real well wait a second yeah
I need to ask you a question because
it seems to me that this is clearly a
troll but it could be one of two
different kinds okay right it could be a
conscious troll who's trying to reveal
how confused civilization has become
because it can't even prevent somebody
with grotesquely technologically
augmented breasts from teaching well
turned out real they're not augmented
breasts they're Prosthetics okay I mean
I must say I have not been paying
attention to the story but it's still
technology yes but it's not augmented
that makes it sound like this person was
walking around like that like all the
time like no okay it gets home he takes
that [ __ ] off okay okay makes makes a
great deal more sense but the point is
it could be one of two different look
yeah can you imagine I mean look you've
got
a zoobie style troll
right now zooby is a person uh I I I
find him to be
quite a wonderful thoughtful person and
what he did as somebody who is very
serious about weight lifting is he
declared himself female and smashed the
uh female dead lifting record and then
went back and his basic point is look
the rules you have set up make this a
completely legitimate phenomenon I have
now just become the weightliftingest
female on earth right because you've set
up a system that is completely uh open
to being gamed by any man who wishes to
do so right
okay so that's a conscious troll that is
well intentioned the purpose is to
reveal the idiocy of the of the truths
that we need so-called truth that we are
now trafficking in right it could also
be one of these other kind of trolls who
have decided oh
you're going to declare transness sacred
I can do anything I want as long as I'm
trans well why not and so you have these
guys taking advantage of it basically
daring civilization uh to call them out
right but if you have successfully been
using power tools for your professional
life yeah and now you've
donned gigantic balloons yeah in front
of you and you've got a wig on and
presumably they're both attached to you
so you know he slices the tip of one of
those prosthesis off it's probably not
going to hurt he gets his hair caught in
a saw that catches him and pulls them
down you know that that could be very
dire indeed these are just these these
aren't reasonable shop practices of
course not uh I'm not disagreeing with
you that it's a troll I'm trying to
figure out whether you imagine that it
is a
well-intentioned troll designed to
reveal that we have all become very
stupid around this issue or it is a
um
an ill-intention troll designed to take
advantage I think I just answered that
question there if if this person has
been a successful shop teacher has been
using
these kinds of tools in his professional
life for some number of years
he would not throw that level of
understanding and safety out the window
in order to pull a malicious prick
it's well
I don't know right but I will say okay
now I get your hypothesis and it makes a
prediction which is that he will reveal
it right right
um if it's well intentional it has to be
revealed
yeah revealed when you know it could be
a lot of things you know maybe
I
I saw a letter
supposedly from the school I don't know
if it's legit that says actually it
would be illegal to not let her you know
Express her gender identity
Bowl but okay
um so you know maybe the hope is that he
gets fired and then he can take it to
court and then you know you don't reveal
it until you know it goes through the
justice system right so I don't know
I've just said like this those for those
pictures and they came out what a week
and a half ago or something are so
preposterous
it seems like it has to be a fake it's
not a fake I mean the the boobs are fake
but you know it's
like this person really did show up in
class and some of the students really
did take uh covert photographs and video
and
um there is apparently
um
protest by parents and some students
outside the school now to you know make
make him stop right and
you know
the the more of that the more people who
are pushed into oh my God I'm not I
don't I don't want to be going out and
protesting but I I have to because this
is insane because that person is not a
woman and my
kid should not be forced to pretend that
that is a woman and to see that and to
have their the entire Downstream
ever the entire rest of their lives
be affected by having had to be in class
with that
that's it's barbaric we've gone barbaric
well it's it's barbaric but I would also
there's a
there is a legal question here right
presumably if a person
so I don't know they still have laws I
know I'm just saying like they don't get
forced I don't know what I don't know
what what you're going to invoke here
but just remember it's not the us we're
talking about okay it's Canada it's a
cold matter of law
um
presumably if a shop teacher
became so fat that they could not
operate the saw yep right yeah then they
couldn't be a shop teacher because it's
not about their fatness it's about the
fact that actually you are physically
incapable of operating the device that
you're supposed to be teaching people
right this person is your point is close
to this it's not fat but what it is is
well if they were real something so
compromising of their ability to safely
operate these kinds of tools
that the point is look it's not about
the it's not about what's under your
shirt it's about the fact that there's
so much of it there that you can't do
the job for which we hired you and
obviously this
we cannot have a civilization in which
you are entitled to hold a job that you
cannot conduct because of
Kink or whatever it is right right we
have to be able to say look one of the
prerequisites prerequisites for this job
is that you can do this job yeah well I
mean this story also just feels to me
like it it gets at this point that we're
making last week we're making the book
that we make all the time about physical
reality versus social reality right I'm
sorry you woke up feeling like a woman
today doesn't make you a woman but that
saw could chop those things off and
that's true and the physical reality of
that saw you've got it plugged into the
wall those electrons are are moving and
so is the blade and I don't care how you
feel
another just the song
physical reality is the physical reality
yeah
the saw is turf yeah physical reality is
a turret for sure all of it
um yes sorry guys
but it is yeah no the
you're right and it's interesting that
this exists
if it is a conscious troll I don't think
it gets revealed after a court case I
don't think it it doesn't go there yeah
um but uh if it is a conscious troll
then you know it does successfully
reveal that we've become so dumb that
when somebody is actually going to put
students in danger because they can't
demonstrate the basic safety protocols
for the equipment in question right that
we still can't bar them from the
classroom of course we have to be able
to do that right but uh I guess just
even if it's not a conscious troll it
reveals that it should in intention
intention of the shop teacher doesn't
change what the fact that the mainstream
media the mainstream media is silence on
this and therefore complicity reveals
that we are just that dumb at this point
yeah regardless of what the intention of
this insane behavior is and I just I'm
I'm just hopeful I like I it just I've
been thinking about this on and off
since I first saw those insane pictures
I went like
I just really hope this guy is in on his
own thing
yeah it's it's presumably better if he
is um but I would point out that we have
a dumb system in which uh you know the
race to get attention has certain
exploitable loopholes and the point is
if you want to take uh
you know a a costume like that to the
next level and create a social confusion
as one team pretends not to notice and
the other team becomes obsessed right
that's a way to you know get to that but
if he was gesticulating in front of
those enormous breasts while talking
about Chaucer the it would it would be
more muddled like how okay you're still
doing sexual display in front of
children and that's unacceptable
um but you're not you know chaucers at
no risk here right yeah I mean Chaucer
would be hard to follow either way but I
don't know I don't know if Charleston or
taught in high school I
is taught in high school I just don't
think it's learned by the way because
it's difficult to yeah to know what it's
all about but it's tough yeah it is
tough that was the right but maybe maybe
toaster okay we're back to toaster so
we've come full circle
again yeah yeah not war war that was
gonna be the sequel yeah no it was war
all along well have we um I think we've
done it we've gotten there apologies uh
for the the snuffling and the snarfling
um but we got through it uh we will be
uh doing our private q a tomorrow uh if
you're listening on September 24th on
September 25th at 11 A.M Pacific you can
find our private q a at my patreon and
uh questions have already been asked but
it's a it's a wonderful It's a Wonderful
group and we can interact with the chat
and all of that so
um if you if you want the Q a that
you've missed today consider joining us
there
anything else to say before we sign off
um I don't think so I guess check out
the Steve Patterson episode of Dark
Horse and the Ramsey rammerman episode
yes in which we discuss Free Speech
section 230 Publishers and platforms and
all of those issues on which everything
seems to hang awesome alright until we
see you next time be good to the ones
you love eat good food and get outside
be well everyone
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]